mr. Perkins must be Thomas Wolfe prefer
to get my rejections in the mail but I
wanted to meet you man you first read
Hemingway f scott Fitzgerald and say
Jesus waiver son of a [ __ ] publisher in
New York hates my book mr. Wolfe we
intend to publish your book max this is
mrs. Bernstein mr. Perkins she's first
person who told me my Rhydon was worth
anything calling you a genius god help
you now I'm a Scribner bestseller I
deserve a little of the hotline max
tells us you're working on a new book
it's about America all of it I have it
in you boo bring it in guys
here you go we can do it how long nine
months if you resist the temptation to
add more I have to be able to add more
the book is 5,000 pages long or take ah
cut cut cut you've been working every
night for two years you have any idea
what it's like coming home to an empty
apartment every month I've lost him to
your husband your daughters they want
their father that's my job it's what I
do two years and the books only 100
pages for free you stop you wouldn't do
this to Hemingway Fitzgerald stop it
you of all people just so damn scared to
live there are other ways to live not
help anyone who loves you Tom because
we're all your millions of beautiful
words you haven't the slightest idea
what it means to be alive max thinks he
created me he crippled me he deformed my
world he made all your dreams come true
he gave you a career
you've done you'll hurt me I can't turn
my back on the world
make your choice Tom that's what we
editors lose sleep over you know we
really making books better or just
making them different oh my love until I
met you I never had a friend a writer
like Tom I get one in a lifetime
you can't your daughter's for the same
lifetime there's one paragraph I have to
add to the book Mike I have to start
adding paragraphs for son this book is
dedicated to maximum efforts Perkins the
author hopes this book will prove worthy
other
idea well if you're good at each
negative hustle start leap